good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
but I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today's
message is choose your own path over to
you Michelle Obama I want I want you all
to stay true to the most real most
sincere most authentic parts of
yourselves I want you to ask those basic
questions who do you want to be what
inspires you how do you want to give
back and then I want you to take a deep
breath and trust yourself to chart your
own course and make your mark on the
world
maybe it feels like you're supposed to
go to law school but what you really
want to do is teach little kids maybe
your parents are expecting you to come
back home after you graduate but you're
feeling a pull to travel the world I
want you to listen to those thoughts I
want you to act with both your mind but
also your heart and no matter what path
you choose I want you to make sure it's
you choosing it and not someone else
everyone around you has a plan for your
life everybody around you your parents
your teachers your friends your
neighbors your grandparents everybody
has an agenda for your time and an
opinion on what you should do with your
life where you should go and a lot of
times it's out of love without a genuine
care and wanting to see you be
successful but success looks different
to different people and so a lot of
people ended up happening is they live
their parents version of their lives
their grandparents version of their
lives to keep going down this path that
is not meant for them and what happens
you may have some success but ultimately
you're not going to be happy because
you're not doing the thing that's inside
of you I know what happens is people
start complaining while I'm stuck on
this path because my parents made me
and now I have to go down this job line
that I don't want to do at some point
you have to decide when you're going to
live your version of your life instead
of your parents or somebody else right
when you're growing up you have to
listen to your parents right when you're
5 years old you're not going to leave
home and say I'm going to go forge my
own path right you're listening to your
parents and you adopt some of their
beliefs and some of their mindsets it's
one of those maybe limiting but at some
point in time whether it's at 12 years
old or 16 years old or 18 years old or
34 years old like at some point you have
to start making decisions for yourself
and say you know what this path that you
want for me it's not the path that I
want for myself I want to go and do this
and I get that you want me to do
something else and that is all that I
love but I need to go down this path and
even if I fail I at least need to know
so if you're not happy with where you're
at you're not happy with the job path
you're at you're not happy with the
relationship path that you're on don't
default to blaming other people it's not
your parents fault anymore it's not your
community's fault anymore you're an
adult take responsibility if you are
unhappy with where you are at in life
it's on you to fix it and that sucks at
the start it's so easy to complain and
to blame somebody else
it'd be great to point the finger and
say it's the president's fault while
you're not successful that's convenient
and easy but it's not the truth and when
you accept that it's on you and you take
accountability and responsibility for
where you are then you also recognize
that you have the ability and you have
the power to change it in a much more
positive direction so the question is a
today is I'm curious what was the moment
in your life that you decided that you
would go and shape your own path when
was that
tell me your story share it down the
comments below super curious to find out
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Jane Cassell Jane take you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word and posting it on Twitter and
LinkedIn
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm glad that you enjoyed the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one
where it is much loved and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]
let's see what is the choice but you
walk a path like everyone else just in
suits go to work and come back and never
have a legacy or you swim upstream like
a drought against norm and then whatever
little you achieve is only your's it's
not like everyone else and I'd rather
have something that is my path waived by
me something that is my legacy my own
self my own achievement than being one
of the many successful people to look
every pursuit no matter how glamorous it
may seem no matter how exciting you are
it feels to you no matter how much you
feel like you were born to do it
comes with a [ __ ] sandwich and so the
question is not what do I love the
question is what do I love so much that
I don't mind eating the sandwich that
comes along with that thing so for me in
my life writing is the thing that I love
and the sandwich was the 7 years that I
was not getting published and that I was
coming home from my job as a diner
waitress as a bartender as an au-pair
as a somebody who worked in flea markets
as a cook and I was coming home tired
and smelling like other people's french
fries and sitting down and doing my real
job which was to write and then to go to
the mailbox the next day and get another
rejection letter and then say Doris
delusion is because this sandwich ha ha
ha ha ha ready to I know and I did still
want to do it and now even as somebody
who makes their living as a writer
there's no end to the sandwiches it's
like oh hello horrible review in
prominent newspaper that's your sandwich
today Liz you still want to do this work
yeah yeah I still do still worth it like
Hello awful comment on social media from
somebody who thinks you're a pile of oh
yeah you know I just have like chosen
every possible way that they can just
cannot get it out of their system fast
enough
how much disregard they have for your
entire life yes still want to do this
thing yeah I still want to do it you
know so that's the question because if
the first time you encounter the
sandwich you're like well this this
isn't worth it then that's not the thing
you're supposed to be doing yeah and
there are plenty of things in life that
that I have run into a sandwich and I've
been like
so not worth it so not worth it like
this is not I want to do this like
whatever the bed alleged benefits of
this thing yes maybe no down SoulCycle
no you know like I know it's probably
really good for me but I feel like
throwing up right now is too hard
come on you'll not be seeing me here
again you know like I'm and I love my
sister's is SoulCycle I just don't like
feeling like I'm going to throw up when
I exercise so it's not for me you know
and and so that's the question so if you
go into this thing thinking if I follow
my bliss and I live my dream and I stand
in my truth then everything will be
great
it doesn't mean everything will be great
it just means at the end of the day when
you check in with yourself
and you know in the end on the balance
is there still better than not doing it
and the answer is still yeah this
thing's still better than not doing it
then you're on the right path I got into
the Air Force because I was it as it
turns out I was romanticizing that whole
idea you know we were refighting World
War two as I was growing up so we had
all these heroic movies and I fell in
love with the idea of flying and then
when I got into the Air Force
I had just big eye-opener that racism
was rampant there also and that I didn't
I not disqualified or suited this better
word for military life that kind of
unquestioning obedience to a lot of
things that I think of stupid didn't
quite go over well yeah so when I got
out I was I was an early discharge it
was almost dishonorable you know because
I just really didn't fit but the
catalyst actually was I did get to sit
in a jet trainer because I
a lot of people behind me to get me into
flight school and stuff but sitting
there it occurred to me that this is
absolutely not what I want it's it isn't
movies it's for real these nano this
little red button on the joystick
controls guns with real bullets and I
said that for quite a while and knew
that if I made a strafing run and needed
a camera here and I needed the people to
be able to get up and go back to number
one so I got out of that plane on the
runway at North Island Air Station a
Naval Air Station and I walked away from
that and towards acting I knew that it
was all about the movies it was all
about the movies